Korean Champ here the president's press
secretary she's articulating the Biden
2024 campaign message for the campaign
Trail Reaganomics doesn't work
sure we believe that trickle down a
trick-or-down economy doesn't work it
has not worked that is shown to be the
case for decades now and so what we have
been very clear you hear me say this all
the time building any comedy from the
from the middle out and bottom up that's
what we want to do and every piece of
historic legislation speaks to that
speaks to what the president wants to do
very loud and clear in historic fashion
Ronald Reagan died almost 20 years ago
Ronald Reagan left office 34 years ago
can we shut up about the Reaganomics
already does this talking point still
work are we going to start talking about
Coolidge and cooler genomics don't work
James Garfield and omics are bad for
this country and I recognize that Joe
Biden remembers the election of James
Garfield and Chester Arthur for most
people this is the distant past